-Hi. I'm Antonio Brown,
and you're watching
"Simms & 'Let-go'"
-[ chuckles ]
What up, "Let-go"?
-Antonio, if you do that again,
you're in big-time trouble, pal!
It is Lefkoe, it is Simms.
That's the way
it should be said.
This is Chris Simms.
He is a football savant.
You know his dad.
Seven years in the NFL.
-Eight years,
you freakin' idiot.
-But he's got a beautiful mind,
watches more film than anybody.
-Right.
And this is Adam Lefkoe,
the host, my work wife,
and the biggest mouth I know,
and he doesn't even --
not that good of a friend.
He didn't know I played
eight years in the NFL.
Thanks, friend.
-Doesn't matter.
We have a lot of friends we're
gonna introduce you to today.
First, young guy.
-This is Sam Darnold!
What?!
And then we go from the
East Coast to the West Coast,
and we got Marcus Peters
coming on, Lefkoe.
-Hanging out with some LA Rams.
What are you best
at gambling at?
-At shooting dice.
-And we sat down with a guy
that took Chris' dad's job,
Tony Romo.
I actually think Sam Darnold,
He's the best quarterback
to come out in a while, period.
-All that is coming up
on "Simms & Lefkoe."
But first, Chris,
a little segment for them.
-It is time
-For Whoa, Big Headline
We had a big headline
over the weekend.
-What?
-We were going nuts.
One of the best
defensive players
in the NFL, Khalil Mack...
-Yes.
-...traded to the Bears,
and Chicago is pumped,
and they should be.
-Holy cow.
-Boom!
Khalil Mack turns the Bears
into a playoff team.
We had them at, like,
the 9-7 wildcard fight.
-Right, the fringe team.
-Are they in?
-I mean, they're scary.
-I want a bold prediction.
-They're scary.
Let me just say this --
Monsters of the Midway.
Khalil Mack, Roquan Smith,
Leonard Floyd, Akiem Hicks --
the Bears defense will be
one of the best in football.
-And we love Vic Fangio.
-We love Vic Fangio.
-And now he has
so many chess pieces.
-Yes, he does.
I look at Khalil Mack
like he used Aldon Smith
a few years back for the 49ers.
Outside linebacker,
defensive end
coming off the edge.
They're gonna create havoc.
Poor Aaron Rodgers.
Watch out for
the Bears' front seven.
-There's a sad side.
-Yeah.
-The Raiders.
I love Raiders fans.
-We love the Raiders.
-Trading Khalil Mack
was the right move
for the Raiders --
the Las Vegas Raiders.
These Oakland people
are getting screwed.
I'm just gonna
put it out there -- this stinks.
-He's the best player
on the team.
It's not even close.
He was the defensive MVP
two years ago.
I don't get it.
It obviously was a money thing.
-Of course.
-But the Raiders defense,
its lack of talent.
-It was already bad.
-It was below average,
and now I don't know
what it is going to be.
-All right, last one.
-Yeah.
-Davis Webb, who was the star of
the off-season, shocking move.
-He's so amazing
in the meeting room.
-He's got binders,
he has playlists for Eli,
and he's brought back
his cowboy boots.
-His arm is so strong...
-How strong is it?
-...it was almost too strong.
-He literally said that.
Here's a thing, though.
They passed on a quarterback
in the draft,
and Davis Webb's like,
"I'm the heir apparent to Eli."
-Right.
-Does this make you question
the Saquon draft with all these
rookie quarterbacks
looking good?
-No. First of all,
Davis Webb, like,
self-appointed him
the heir apparent to Eli,
so pump the brakes there.
Giant fans want Eli.
That's all they cried for
the last year and a half.
I'll tell you what I'm worried
about with the Giants.
If Eli gets hurt, their backup
quarterbacks are not very good.
This just in -- doo-doodle-doo,
doo-doodle-doo!
-That's breaking news.
-Thank you.
-So, we do know that Webb
is going to the Jets,
but the future, as you mention,
Sam Darnold.
We got Sam Darnold, rented a
little car, just us three guys.
-Little fun.
-Wanted to show him
New York City,
but we did invite some friends.
-J-E-T-S --
Jets, Jets, Jets!
[ cheers and applause ]
-Are we ready to give Sam
a tour of the city?
-Yeah!
-Let's go!
-Wave to your admirers.
They're out there.
Win over New York.
-Let's go, Giants!
-Yeah.
-All righty.
-You're gonna have to hear that
today. I'll shut them up.
Did you have to do
any rookie hazing yet?
Have you had to take everybody
to dinner or anything?
-I had to sing.
I had to sing, yeah.
-What'd you go with?
-"Thousand Miles."
- by Vanessa Carlton.
-Yeah.
-  Da-na-na, na-na-na-na.
-I just want to admit something.
-Yeah.
-I'm a little upset that you get
to sit next to Sam.
-When you were briefed
about this, they were like,
"Yeah, you're gonna sit..."
-You're from Philadelphia.
-You're right.
I don't know this area too well.
-'Cause when me and Chris
are talking,
you're not even really
part of it, you know?
-To really know New York,
there are a certain group
of people that are royalty.
-Yeah.
-And this is
the fire department.
-I feel like that's something
that I want to be a part of,
maybe after playing football.
-So let's go meet some
of your biggest fans.
-Let's do it.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, he's here!
-How you doing?
All righty, guys.
Good to meet you.
-Face of the Jets meeting
the face of the city.
-Sam's grandfather
was a fireman.
-Yeah, in LA.
-Truly special to him.
But we told him no going down
the fire pole today
or anything like that.
We got to draw the line.
-Yeah, Coach Bowles --
Coach Bowles
might get a little mad.
Pray for me.
-Oh, there he is.
-This is my boy.
This is my proud boy.
He's becoming a New York man.
-It is hot in here.
-Dude, he looks like
a fireman, right?
[ horn blares ]
-What's up?
Fireman for the day.
Oh, that's so much power.
This is so cool.
Get the hell outta my way!
What're you doin'?!
[ horn blaring ]
I can only imagine
if I was wearing the jacket.
-You're a natural.
-Oh, yeah. That was fun.
-You're a New Yorker now.
-It's official.
-Is that the number-one thing
you hear, like,
so far from Jet fans,
like "I hope you beat the Pats"?
-Yeah.
-That's right.
-Got to beat Brady
and those guys.
-Right.
-"Belichick and those guys."
-Yeah.
-We got to beat some
other teams, too.
-Now I'd like to see
some action.
Simms still thinks he can throw.
I don't know if he thinks
he can throw like
the third pick in the draft.
-Yeah.
-I'm just No. 97.
-I'm gonna go out there,
and I'd like to see
who can hit my trash can.
-Sam's going first.
Sometimes Texas beats USC.
Oh.
-Oh, Simms --
Simms has the line.
-Oh!
[ crowd ohhs ]
-Go.
[ cheers and applause ]
-Whoo!
42nd Street, Times Square.
What?!
This is Sam Darnold!
The Jets rule!
Get your ass outta here!
-How many fights
have you been in?
That's the question
I want to get to.
-I'm serious.
He's just picking fights.
-I can be confrontational.
Who's your team?
-Cowboys!
-Oh, when's the last time
you won a Super Bowl?
-When's the last time
y'all won a Super Bowl?!
-I don't know, but he's gonna
win it real soon, right here.
Let's start it up.
Here we go.
-J-E-T-S -- Jets, Jets, Jets!
-I want to be best friends
with Sam Darnold,
and I'm working on it.
-Yeah, yeah.
Stalker alert.
-Call me, Sam!
I miss you!
Welcome to Lefkoe's GIF Shop.
It's where Simms knows football,
I know the internet,
and I try to teach you
the internet through GIFs,
which I think are
the best part of the internet.
-Please teach me, oh wise one,
cuz I am clueless
about the internet.
I'm gonna show you a GIF,
I'm gonna give you
a football take,
you tell me if I'm right.
First GIF is this one.
Thanos.
This is what I believe
J.J. Watt will be,
re-entering the NFL this season.
-Oh, man, I still can't believe
the Avengers lost this battle.
I'm so heartbroken about it.
-Spoilers!
-Sorry, deal with it.
And, no, J.J. Watt can't
beat Thanos!
He's, like, the most charitable
nice guy in the world.
This guy's evil!
He's bad.
Sorry.
-Yeah, but getting back, just
tearing up offenses with a snap.
-He is scary
and has a similar jaw,
but that's about it.
-Next GIF in the GIF Shop
is this bad boy.
-[ laughs ]
I love this!
-This is the Ravens defense
reacting to Nathan Peterman
starting in week 1.
-That's awesome.
Funny how!
-Funny clown!
-Yeah, I bet.
-They got to be thrilled.
-Yeah.
And, I mean, seriously,
Nathan Peterman
needs to be scared for his life.
-Over-under, three interceptions
for Nathan Peterman.
-I'm gonna go und--
But the real question is,
over-under,
five sacks on Nathan Peterman.
I'm going over.
-Oh, my gosh.
Funny how!
[ both laugh ]
All right, next GIF.
This is the Lefkoe GIF Shop!
This is what defenses
are gonna be like
when they face Jimmy G
and Kyle Shanahan this season.
-Oh, I feel that.
They're gonna be like, "What?!
Where's it coming from, man?!
Shanahan's offense and Jimmy G
is so handsome!
We can't stop this!
This is unbelievable!"
-Is it gonna be awesome
to watch?
-I think it is.
-30 points a game?
-30 points a game.
Jimmy G, slam dunk, top five
statistical quarterbacks
in the sport this year.
-Oh, that's amazing.
-Yes, it is.
-I like that.
Well, we have a next guest
that was a top-five guy
back in his heyday.
Again, the guy that stole
your dad's job.
-Thank you.
Keep talking about that.
-Tony Romoski.
Again, though, you get to sit
next to the quarterback,
first Sam Darnold
and now Tony Romo.
-Yeah, sorry.
That's just what happens.
It's a quarterback thing, man.
You stay over there, host.
-Yeah, thanks a lot.
I appreciate it.
-But Sam Darnold,
we spent time with him.
And I said coming out
of the draft,
one of the pro player
comparisons
I kind of compared it
to is your style of play.
I said, "Tony Romo, the way
he manipulates the pocket
and can move around
and subtly move and make throws.
So, we're interested in just
your thought on him,
specifically, and then,
of course, some of the rookie
QBs that have jumped out to you.
-Without making any
glaring statements...
-Yeah.
-Ooh.
-...but I'm about to.
-Yes.
-I actually think Sam Darnold
is got a chance to end up,
at some point,
-Right.
- to be the best quarterback
in the National Football League.
-Okay.
-In the whole league?
-In the whole league.
I actually think he's the best
quarterback to come out
in a while, period.
-Kind of a glaring statement.
-There it is.
Some people just have this
rare ability for nuance
that I say are feel.
You know, we talk about --
-Feel the tackles
creeping up into you
when you're getting
ready to throw.
You just move, and you don't
even know why you move.
-You don't even know
why you moved.
-You had that, dude.
-That's why
there's a similarity.
-But he's further along
than I am in the sense
that it took me years to get
the base to be strong and set,
where he's coming in like that,
which is more Peyton Manning-ish
than I've seen
of anybody coming out.
And I know it's a pretty bold
statement and stuff,
but I'm willing,
based on what I've seen,
I feel very confidently that --
I don't know if he's gonna have
a good year this year,
but I guarantee you
within the next three years,
Sam Darnold is for real.
-One guy that definitely knows
the details is Belichick.
You're gonna have to sit
with him before
the first game of the year.
Are you prepared
for your meeting with Belichick?
What is that like when
you have to sit there
and ask that man questions
in a closed room?
- You know he walks in, it's Belichick,
as you already know.
-Right.
-And sure enough,
he's got a suit on
that's four times too big.
You know, it's just --
it's like --
-His style is absurd.
-He sits there and he...
-He doesn't smile or anything.
-Walks in, he just
sits there and...
-Nantz is like,
"Do you want to go first, Tony?"
I was like, "No, you --
you're going first."
Go ahead.
It's like, "Hey, Coach."
Belichick's just like...
-Yeah.
-And then he's like...
"So, what are you --
You guys look like you're gonna
be pretty good this year.
Got a good squad
and everything."
He's like...
-Trying.
-That's his -- That's it.
It's really like that, though.
-No words?
-No, he's just gonna shrug.
-Dude, you're making me
uncomfortable.
-That's how it is.
It's the most uncomfortable
like 10 seconds.
So then it comes to my turn
to talk, and I'm like --
I don't even care
about his team.
Then I just start talking
about the Giants in the '80s.
-You bring stuff up,
and he goes down history lane,
and that's when he opens up.
-Yeah.
-First, he goes out,
he takes your dad's job.
-"Mister, mister,
I have no more money!
My family!
You told my --
My dad's job is gone.
Do you have any money
on you, mister?"
And then,
what, are you stealing
my coach's job now, too?
-I got a job.
-Yes, you do now, huh?
-So you know what that means.
-I got to pay for my kids,
how to eat, too.
Got to make ends meet.
I'm not playing anymore.
I'm barely making ends meet.
-Simms, are you ready for it
to become "Romo & Lefkoe"?
-"Romo --"
Yes, that's next, huh?
-No, but seriously,
we're gonna take this chair out.
-Seriously.
-No, seriously.
-Seriously, no, you need
to get out of here.
-Seriously.
-I'm top.
-There he is.
He's got you.
I'm Chad Johnson.
And I'm Terrell Owens.
And you're watching "The Simms and Lefkoe Show".
I don't like that.
-They're awesome.
-They are awsome.
-They are like us.
- They are.
But accomplished.
-Yeah, that's right.
-I'm so excited now
with gambling.
I love to bet on games.
I always steal his information.
I try to make money on it.
And you did me a favor.
I wanted to bet
against the players.
You called Sean McVay
and got me into Rams camp.
-Well, getting you
into camp's not easy,
so I had to pull
some big-time strings.
We are here with a quarterback's
best friend,
and his name is C-o-o-o-o!
Ooh, they like it!
Ooh!
You would've thrown
to this guy a lot
when you were playing, huh?
-Yeah.
-How many touchdowns did his
dependable hands
catch last year?
-He was a rookie sensation,
Lefkoe.
Five last year.
-All right.
So, I am a degenerate gambler.
I want to bet on how many
touchdowns you get this year.
So, set the line.
How many touchdowns
do you think you're going
to catch this season?
-Well, obviously,
we're gonna trend upwards.
-Ooh!
-Let's give it a...
Let's go at nine.
-Wow!
Nine touchdowns.
That's a lot.
I'm looking at your team.
I'm seeing Cooks and Woods.
I'm seeing Gurley.
I'm seeing all those tight ends.
-You're not gonna
hurt my feelings.
You just need to make your bet.
-That's right.
He loves to open his big mouth
and change the subject.
I know.
-Let me justify
what I'm gonna say.
-Watch out. I'm not changing
the subject, Simms.
I am gonna take the under,
but I am gonna make this bet.
If it does go under,
I get a win.
If it goes over, nine or over,
I will donate $1,000
to the Wimberly's and their help
for the youth in Cambodia.
Is that a fair deal to you?
-Sounds good to me.
-All right, so, here's the deal.
I'm a gambler, okay?
I do "Lefkoe's Locks."
-I'm good at gambling, though.
-Are you really?
-Yeah.
-Well, we're gonna
gamble right now.
So I'm curious
how many interceptions
do you think
you're gonna have this season?
-I'mma go with, uh...
-Set the line.
-Set the line, set the line.
-I'm gonna go with seven.
-Seven.
-Yeah, I'll go with seven.
-I'm gonna say that you go over
seven interceptions this year.
If I'm right, then I get a win.
I get a Lefkoe Lock.
If I'm wrong,
I'm going to donate
$1,000 to the Fam 1st charity.
-Appreciate it.
-Yes?
Do you take my bet?
-Yeah, I'll take that bet.
-It's a bet.
This means we're gonna watch you
the entire season.
We're gonna keep a Marcus Peters
interception tracker.
-You feel me? I got you.
-We're joined by, I would say,
arguably, the greatest punter
to ever play in the NFL.
-He's definitely the best
in the sport right now.
-Not only does he punt,
though, Simms.
He also throws passes.
What is his average
completion per year?
-Per year, he is 1 1/2
completions per year,
about the same as mine
for my career at quarterback.
We're about equal.
-How many completed passes
do you think
you will have this season?
-I mean, the line's got to be 2.
It's got to be
just over average.
-So two.
-Yeah.
-I'm gonna take the under.
-Okay.
-How does that make you feel?
-I'm ready to rise above it.
-Yeah, rise above it.
Screw this guy.
-Should I set it at 2 1/2?
-No, you're two, you said it.
He took it.
- The hell with him.
- Yeah that's right, there you go.
-So here's how this
is gonna work.
If you get under two,
I get a Lefkoe Lock.
If you get over two,
I will donate $1,000 to the
Special Olympics in your name.
-I love that.
-Is that a deal?
- That  would be great.
- Yeah!
We got it right there.
-Yeah.
-It's a Lefkoe Lock!
-If you go over two,
I'm wearing your jersey
on the podcast.
-I want to bet on the premier
game in the NFL each week.
You know exactly what
I'm talking about --
Thursday Night Football.
So I went to my bosses
at Bleacher Report
and said,
"Guys, I need $5,000."
-They said, "Lefkoe, you got it.
One catch."
I said, "What?"
They said,
"You can't pick the teams."
Fine.
I know New York.
I know New York well.
I went around the city,
and each week,
I'm gonna find a random person
to pick the game
against the spread.
If they're right,
I'll split the winnings.
It's a little segment we call
"Somebody & Lefkoe."
Thanks, Adam.
You're the best.
All right, I'm here with Allie.
-Yes, sir.
-We are here,
we're selling newspapers.
Hey, you want a Starburst?
Awesome.
Allie is gonna be my bettor
for week 1, Eagles-Falcons.
Bleacher Report has
given me money.
-Okay.
-I'm gonna let you
make the pick.
If you get it right,
I'm splitting
my winnings with you.
-I like it.
-If you get it wrong,
you will never see me again
for the rest of your life.
-Mm.
-Which we kind of have
a friendship now.
I feel bad.
-Yes, yes.
I have some information.
-Okay.
-First, this is an eagle,
and this is a falcon.
Soak it in.
-Got it.
-Okay, next.
Famous fans.
The Eagles have Kevin Hart.
The Falcons have Ludacris.
-Luda.
-Okay.
He said, "Luda."
He may have just been swayed.
Lastly, two of the best players
on the team.
The Eagles have Fletcher Cox.
The Falcons have Matt Ryan.
-Mm-hmm.
Allie, who's your pick?
-Look, you got to believe
that the Eagles
are gonna come out
week 1 gunning.
I like the Eagles.
He's taking the Eagles!
"Simms & Lefkoe,"
first bet of the season.
Allie is going the right birds,
the Eagles.
If you're right, I'm bringing
cash back to this stand,
and I'm not buying anything.
I'm just gonna give it to you.
-Not if I'm right.
I'll see you then.
-Ooh.
Back to you, "Simms & Lefkoe."
What do you think?
Allie gonna be right?
Eagles gonna win by 3?
-I think he can sell
some newspapers,
but, man, is he wrong.
Your Eagles are gonna lose.
Sorry, Lefkoe.
-Just flat-out lose?
-Flat-out lose, yeah, sorry.
-You're the best.
I love you.
-Rise up, Atlanta.
-Oh, go, Birds.
All right, so, let's get
some Super Bowl picks
since it is our first show.
My Super Bowl's a little crazy.
-Oh. Disclaimer.
-But I'm feeling confident.
I'm going with Aaron Rodgers
and the Packers
to out-duel Deshaun Watson
and the Texans.
I like it.
-I mean, I like it, too.
It's your two favorite players,
and you put them
on the Super Bowl together.
But, unfortunately,
it's a team sport, Lefkoe, okay?
-So who you going with?
-I'm going with the S's --
the Saints, the Steelers,
Super Bowl LIII.
Steelers World Champs!
How you like them apples?
-Way to really play it safe.
-Yeah, I just want to be right.
Sorry.
-That's a good pick, though.
Good luck.
-Hey, appreciate that.
-Before we go,
I want to give you guys
something for Sunday.
When you're watching the games
and all this attention's
been put on the helmet rule,
we're starting a hashtag.
-Yes.
-Any time a flag gets thrown
that you're like,
"Are you kidding me?"
use the hashtag
#KeepItInYourPants.
-We're talking about flags.
Yep.
-Okay don't, you sickos.
#KeepItInYourPants.
-We're talking about flags.
-Thank you very much.
That was "Simms & Lefkoe."
Before we go,
you've noticed our set.
It's really beautiful.
We have a lot of
cool trinkets and gifts.
I wanted to give you a gift
'cause it's our first show.
He doesn't know about this.
It's to add to our studio.
I would like you to open it.
I spent a lot of money on this.
-I don't think you did anything,
work wife.
I got to check this out.
-I spent a lot of money on this.
-A lot of money?
-Like, my whole paycheck.
Do you know how to open gifts?
-I see what this is, though.
-Pull it out.
-Wow!
-Yes.
-Where did you buy this?
They still sell these?
$5.
I was gonna say,
you got ripped off for $5.
-There was a thrift store
in Manhattan.
A Chris Simms jersey for $5.
We're gonna put it right
behind your bronzed spleen.
-Oh, thank you very much.
I really appreciate that.
I cannot believe they're still
being sold in stores.
-And I can't believe
they gave us a show.
"Simms & Lefkoe."
Appreciate you guys so much.
That's it for Simms.
-Peace out, homies.
-I'm Lefkoe.
In the words of Antonio Brown,
"Let-go."
Talk to you guys next week.
Uh oh.
Oh man., there is so much pressure on this kid.
Ohh...Wooo!
Same route.
Just go long.
Please catch it.
Yeah!
He's like whatever
I do this in my sleep.